Hey traders, it's Mike here. And you
know, a question I get so often is, you
know, what what's your favorite order
flow trading setup? And you know, I I
have a handful of them that I always
look for because, you know, you always
have to have different setups for
different market conditions, right?
Market could be a trending day and
you're going to look for certain type of
setup there. You're going to market
could be a rotational day and you're
going to you know, you're trying to
trade a a breakout
way of trading on on a rotational day or
or a non-trend day, you're you're going
to suffer. But one that I found that
works in many different market
conditions. Obviously, it's going to
outperform in trending markets cuz you
could just let it run. But, you know, it
it even works in rotational markets is
the value area
that you're looking at in the order
flow. Now, on order flows trader, uh you
know, one of our tools that we have on
the order flows trader is the ability to
look at the actual value area for each
bar. That's why you see some bars have
uh a green sort of uh box rectangle and
some have a red one. That is the value
area. And the value area is where 70% of
the volume uh transacted in that bar.
You know, it's a it's a very
um
What do you want to call it? It's it's a
very low setting compared to, you know,
looking at the volume profile for the
day because you're looking at it on a
bar-by-bar basis. So, if you're looking
at a 1-minute bar, it's going to be the
the 1-minute value area. If you're
looking at a 5-minute bar, you're going
to be looking at a what? A 5-minute
value area. If you're looking at a 2,500
volume chart, it's going to be the value
area for that 2,500 bar. Now, in the
order flows trader setting,
um you can see down here we have a few
things. We have the value area, right?
If you want to enable it, you just put
the check box there. The draw mode will
keep it at fixed. You can have it until
tested. But,
this is the important one here. This is
a new feature that we added
on Order Flows Trader 8. It's value area
absorption.
Because again, you know, every bar is
going to have a value area because, you
know, it trades volume. And what we
found is some value areas actually show
signs of absorption.
And why is that important? It's because,
you know, anytime you could identify
absorption and you start moving away
from that absorption,
you know, you're starting to see
initiative trading come in and that's
where big trends can happen. So, what
we're going to do is we're going to draw
that until tested because I want to be
identifying the times that we move away
from that absorption.
And
it's going to be colored blue. Value
area absorption is going to be dark
blue. Value area bullet bearish is going
to be a
deep pink. Now, I don't want to confuse
it with just the normal value area. So,
what I'm going to do is for the normal
bullish value area, meaning a green bar,
um it's going to show a green value
area. For a red bar, it will show a red
value area. What I'll do is just make
the normal bars
I don't want to see those value areas,
right? Because
it's not as important as a value area
absorption. Okay, so what I've done is
I've made them transparent.
So, I'll click apply. Okay, so now what
I'm going to be looking at, right, on my
chart is I'm just going to be seeing the
bullish value area absorption and the
bearish value area absorption.
And if the market starts to move away
from it, the draw mode is until tested,
meaning it's going to draw out a zone.
Okay, so
here, right, you can see now
sort of this outline around the regular
value area for the green bars and the
red bars.
This is value area absorption. This is
absorption.
And we're seeing some absorption come in
here. Why it's blue because it's
bullish. Why it's red because it's
bearish. Now,
that's all well and good. Okay?
Remember, we're looking at value area on
a very small time frame. This is a
1-minute chart. So, with that in mind,
what I want to be noticing is when the
market is
pulling away from it, moving away from
it immediately. Okay? Because that's
where being trends are going to come.
That is where you have that initiative
trading coming in.
Okay? So, it's one thing to have bullish
absorption, bearish absorption, but
really what you want the market to be
doing now is starting to move away from
it. And that's why we draw them out
until fixed. Boom. Here you got one
right here.
Okay? And you see this move, you know,
this is coming in around
um the 7498 area right in here, you
know, because obviously
with you know, this bar has to close.
You got to know where that value area
is, but more importantly this next bar
is coming in and it doesn't trade into
it. It's what we call an abandoned value
area. And in this case it's an abandoned
um
value area that has absorption. So, I
know that if if this next bar doesn't
trade anywhere in there, we're going to
be looking for this market to move up.
So, where you going to be getting long
actually is after this second bar
closes. So, this is your
sort of your signal that, hey, you know,
what? I've got that bullish abandoned
value area, but it's not confirmed that
it's abandoned until this bar forms and
closes. So, where you getting long is in
this red bar here. So, you got the whole
1 minute to be getting long somewhere in
here, 7,500.
Okay?
And you could just see what the market
did after this, right? It just ran
straight up. You know, right now we're
trading what? 75 38. So from 75
basically 75 double O got up to 10 up to
20 up to 30 and it's pushing 40.
Okay, and that is
during the US hours. Obviously if if
you're looking during
you know, pre I'll say pre market but
you know, the cash opens at 8:30 Chicago
time. Yeah, there was a little signal
that came in here at 8:00 21. Again, you
know, I don't think you should really be
taking any trades right ahead of the
cash open because you're going to get a
bar like this on the cash open which can
stop you out either way.
From 8:00 we did have a bearish signal
here, you know, and it did sort of
pulled back up and then went back went
down.
Again, you know, 8:00 it's a little bit
close to
the cash open anyway.
You know, this was a better trade to
take than this one. I think it's just
too close to the cash open.
Um
you know, just but again, and if you're
trading during the the evening session,
you just got to realize you know,
sometimes the moves are going to be a
little bit shorter
simply because you're not getting that
movement, you know, although with
everything going on in the world, you
know, Trump's in China right now, who
knows what's going to happen during
Asian hours. But here's a nice one,
right? Where you're going to be getting
short somewhere in this bar because this
is your
your
value area.
But you don't know it's abandoned until
this bar forms. Once this bar trades and
doesn't trade back into it, that's your
gold signal. Getting short somewhere
around here, I don't know, 74 93 and a
half and you can see it drops down
into the 80s. Okay.
Again, you know, that's at 6:00 in the
morning. You know, just really quick.
Um
doesn't matter what market you're you're
looking at. You could be looking at you
know, I like ultra bonds. I like you
know, I like interest rates on not on a
time based chart but on a range-based
chart because on a time-based chart, you
know, a lot of times it's just going to
trade the bid and the offer. That's why
I like to use a
range-based chart. So, you know, the
chart's constructed based off of moves.
And you can see here at the high of the
day, this is today in the ultra bonds.
Did have a bearish signal come in right
after bullish one. Okay, fine. I can
live with that. Here last
night,
we did have a nice bearish signal. Well,
the market did come back in, traded 11
lots. But again, it doesn't stop you out
if you were to hold this one. This was a
beautiful trade, you know, getting long
somewhere in here. Right? With You know,
look at that, what you're risking.
You're risking basically one, two,
three, four, five ticks.
Right? And and you know, it got all the
way up into the 20s.
This one, you know,
this is a bullish one, you know, if
you're getting long in here, but then it
comes back with the bearish one, you
know, right now it's just sort of going
sideways. But look at the day before.
Okay?
Here, let's just go back a couple days.
Um
I mean, this is you know, you're not
going to take the trade uh yesterday. I
believe we had CPI that came out at
7:30. So, you're probably not looking to
take this one.
Um
you had a bearish one here, then a nice
bullish one where it went up to a
bearish one, back down. Um
you know, even uh what it looked like
the day before. Day before very clean.
You had just had this one signal right
here.
And then this nice just move down all
day long.
Okay? Even
just going back a little bit further.
Okay? It was a nice bearish signal that
came in
um here.
Okay? You had a bullish one here. And
again, you know, there's not much out of
this move, but you know, this one's
coming in at uh
basically about midnight. This one's
coming in.
I think that was Monday, Um right around
7:30, but then you got this nice bearish
one and it just continued on down.
Pulled back where you got the next
bearish signal and went down. That is
ultra bonds. You could even, you know,
currencies, euro currency.
Okay, he could be on a time base chart.
I don't, you know, this is a four range
chart. You can see the signals here. Um,
one thing to note, okay, especially if
you're on a short time frame, like four
range,
in uh currencies,
this bar,
right? It's not a green candle, it's not
a red candle, it's a doji candle, just
as this one. It's got this sort of
golden area drawn around it.
Um, you you just watch how the market
came out of it afterwards. This is also
a doji bar here.
Um, cuz the candle's not red, it's not
green.
Okay.
But again, you know, I think a four
range is a bit quick on this market. I
prefer an eight range. So, I know some
guys like to use a 10 range, but I think
a eight range is is good enough for
currencies. That's what I've always
uh looked at, but you can see, right?
Bearish signals here, bearish signal
here, bearish signal here, bullish
signal here, right? Even if you just
catch this last one, you know, you're
talking a move down from, you know,
117.08
down into uh 116.
90, you know, then obviously you got
some small winners here, small winner
here, small winners there. So, again,
you know, it's a very easy setup to use.
It's value area absorption. Um, it's
available on the Order Flow Suite Trader
software.
Doesn't take anything fancy. You don't
have to read what's taking place in the
delta. I mean, you can, you can add all
that in. I mean, you can even uh turbo
boost it by adding in, you know, extra
signals such as imbalance reversals, um,
prominent point of controls. You could
add all that in, but
you don't even need to, honestly. I
mean, yeah, it will give you maybe some
stronger, potentially stronger trades,
but at the same time you're going to
have fewer trades. It's just very simple
to see, right? I mean, you could you
could look at, you know, any market.
Um
I don't know what crude's going to look
like. Crude's pretty fast right now, but
um
I don't think you can eight range I
think is too fast for crude. Think you'd
have to use something like a 15 range
chart now in in crude sort of capture
decent movements, but what you're
seeing, you know, some nice bearish
signals can coming in here, here.
Um
Yeah, a question I get a lot is what
about Nasdaq?
Okay, well
Nasdaq
Nasdaq's very volatile.
Okay, so
um
moves very quick. We'll just use uh the
Nasdaq what we can use is a 30-second
chart.
Looking for that value area absorption.
Um
So, let's just pull up the chart really
quick here.
Okay, so here's my Nasdaq and is there
any any
signals? Um you know, there's one little
short that came in here that didn't
really work out.
It sort of came right back and snapped
back up. Again, this is just a 30-second
chart. I'll just pull something up.
And you know, here's a couple nice
little bullish ones coming in here.
Right here.
Whoops.
Here.
Here. I mean, we're talking a move from
What is that? Basically 29
590 got all the way up to, you know,
660. Even along the way, you know,
around 620, 630, there was another
another signal that came in.
Again, you know, you're talking to move
from 590 up to 660, so a 70 point move.
See if there's any other ones here.
There's a nice bearish one that came in
here. Yeah, some bullish ones. There's a
nice
Here's a nice couple after cash open.
Now, this is interesting. Um
So, you got this
bullish one here that's coming in around
you know, where you would you be getting
long somewhere in here, so around 540,
shoots up to 600 where you got the
bearish signal.
So, you're getting short in here, but
then it comes back. So, you you take a
small loss probably.
Um you know, somewhere in here.
What whatever this loss would be, we're
talking
you know, maybe 25 points, but you had a
nice bullish signal that came in here
from, you know,
590,
gets all the way up to almost 680.
Then you got a nice bearish signal here.
640, but realistically, you're probably
getting short somewhere in here around
600.
Right? Drops
within the next few minutes, gets all
the way back down to 540. So,
you know, that's another 60 points
right there. All right?
And then, you see it starts working its
way back up again. So, even on the
Nasdaq, right, which is pretty volatile,
and again, you don't you're not
analyzing every single tick that goes
through.
You're just analyzing that value area.
So, you know, that's that's
to me, that's the uh
you know, that's the beauty of
looking at the value areas, right? And
and you want to be looking at the value
areas that matter, right? That's why we
identify
the value areas that have absorption. So
again, you know, it's only available on
the Order Flows Trader 8 because it's
it's my own proprietary study
for traders.
Okay? So
again, you know, link is in the
description below and and thanks for
watching this.